Hi everyone, I'd like to show you a nice new feature that we've added to Burp Suite.
This is to pretty print JSON and other content in the HTTP message editor.
I'm going to the PortsWigger website and clicking on Daily Swig.
Daily Swig is our new site covering cybersecurity, breaches, bug bounties and other security news.
If we look under the hood, the feed of stories on the front page is actually being loaded using JSON.
Here we can see in Burp Suite what the JSON coming from the website actually looks like.
And it's pretty hard to read. Everything's flattened onto one line.
You can't see the structure of the data. It's hard to see the keys and values.
With the new Burp feature, the JSON now looks like this.
It's nicely formatted and much more readable.
You can easily see the structure and read the contents.
The same applies to other data formats like JavaScript, CSS, HTML, XML.
It also works for HTTP requests containing data in JSON or other formats.
You can toggle between pretty printing and the original view by clicking the pretty button.
We'll be adding a bunch more prettifying features like this in future.
As always, do let us know if you have any feedback. And have fun!
We'll be adding a bunch of data.